Hey what's up guys? Today we are back with another dry ice experiment.
Today we're testing out to see what happens with dry ice down a waterslide. [let's] go find out
Yeah
Dude, that was amazing it felt like floating on a cloud except these little chunks of dry ice [could] like [skim] [it] up my back
I think you got some down your shorts guys check this out. This is what happens when dry ice makes contact with your skin
It's almost like a burn like a freezer burn, but that's going to swell [up] and probably stand there for four or [five] days
But super awesome the water is amazingly warm today. We're having a great time and we're definitely doing that again right now
Look at that that. That is where I just got hit by a chunk of dry ice it's like in the hit by rocks
so needless to say this is [not] an experiment that should we try to home leave this to the trained experts and
Professionals this right here is for demonstrational and educational purposes only anyway. We'll see you [guys] in the next video
Never use these gopros before Ellen draw 800 bucks